yo where have you been what happened
after we lost you you were wandering in
the party looking for more credit more
kind of bitch that's an internet drug
okay shh-shh you're you're asking me
dude I just woke up and he was next to
me in bed okay okay we'll figure this
out together for you spooning yeah but
were you bigger a little okay I just
woke up and this dude was in my bed I
have no idea who he take or little big
interesting okay tell me a little bit
about your experience with him was there
for play was it good did he think of the
four player did you have to request it
did you fondle his balls I understand
why that information would be necessary
right now okay Abbi
not all men like or want ball fondling
okay sometimes they want to tug
sometimes they want to rake sometimes I
want to squeeze them does they want a
little tickle I'm just trying to narrow
it down to see if we know I do okay so
fine I grab his wallet out of his back
right pocket of his jeans
what do you trust me do it hey um whoa
dude how did you know that you know all
men are the same to an extent I are
these guys he's got a lot of cash you
mean he's rich got coffee punch cards my
kind of guy right okay this is that my
wallet hey that's my Christmas money
what's his name what's his name
uh-huh final
[Music]